are you aware of the never swing The
Rock memes about you no I'm aware of of
the little Michael never swing The Rock
Porter Jr I don't know who came up with
that but to be completely honest getting
a lot of assists is not my role on on
the Nuggets you know what I mean Joker
and Jamal they play their two-man game
if it gets swung out to me by one of
those guys I'm expected to shoot it I'm
one of the best Shooters in the league
like humbly like I can say that but like
I don't see contests so a lot you might
be watching on TV and see me shoot a
contested shot but it doesn't feel
contested to me I might watch it like
after I'm filming like yo I shot that
but really they don't feel contested